eh sì perché proprio un periodo in cui ho
voglia di cambiare di rivoluzionarmi e
infatti stavo pensando no volevo un tuo
parere a riguardo ma se mi facessi tipo
la frangia?
adoro è da una vita che ti dico di fare
la frangia no vabbè ma falla subito
immediatamente amo stai scherzando spero
la frangia é una condanna a vita ma sei
impazzita
io l'ho fatta a nove anni sai quando mi
sono ricresciuti i capelli a 15 no
assolutamente bocciata non ti parlo più
mary ma sai che ti sta proprio bene
questa frangia ma non pensavo ti enfatizza lo
sguardo poi ti dá un'aria più fresca più
giovanile più sbarazzina brava hai fatto
bene a farla a me proprio non piace
questa frangia io te l'avevo detto hai
fatto una cavolata cioè ti copre
proprio lo sguardo ma poi ti invecchia
dai con sta frangia hai preso 20 anni cioè
stavi molto meglio senza te l'avevo detto io
tutti mi dicevano che avere la frangia era
scomodo é comodissimo ho passato il phon
un attimo e guarda qui perché non si
stira
sembra sempre sporca cavolo no ma è
infatti mi piace un sacco addirittura ti
giuro stavo pensando di accorciarla
ancora un po sì un po più radical chic
un po più estrema vero rimedi per far
crescere in fretta i capelli soluzioni
per far crescere la frangia fai da te
economiche e poi il bello della frangia é
che basta una forcina e voilà la francia
sparisce perfetta e se mi stufo della
frangia basta una semplice forcina e il
gioco è fatto
la frangia è sparita dovrebbe
teoricamente sparire non sparisce
-quindi quando sarete in disaccordo dovrete parlarne poi dovrete votare la
soluzione ma tu potrai snobbare qualcun
altro più tardi e alla fine tutti gli
snobbati saranno in parità ed è così che
funziona l'america- non farti la frangia
che ti vengono i brufoli
fino a prova contraria non ho mai avuto
la pelle così perfetta sono solo dicerie
vedrai quanti brufoli ti vengono con la
francia io l'ho fatta ieri e guarda cosa
cosa diavolo è successo alla mia fronte
vedi non bisogna ascoltarle le persone
se ti fai la frangia la dovrei lavare
ogni tre minuti perché si sporcherà
sempre é da due giorni che non li lavo e sono
perfetti guarda
ma come ho lavato i capelli ieri sera come è
possibile che la frangia sia lercia
sporca schifosa devo fare qualcosa
la lavo lavo la frangia e basta ma
non hai capito quanto sto cuccando da
quando mi sono fatta la frangia cioè sono
proprio rock and roll mi sento più
stilosa più sicura di me stessa ma
guarda se tornassi indietro la
rifarei mille altre volte proprio la svolta
hai ragione
dovevo ascoltarti non mi crescerà mai
non la voglio piú mi fa schifo questa
frangia maledetta me me la strappo
eccoci arrivati alla fine del video come
potete notare non mi sono fatta la
frangia é una frangia finta fatemi
sapere con un commentino qui sotto se
avete la
frangia oppure se non ce l'avete o se
vi piacerebbe farla se non l'avete
ancora fatto mi raccomando iscrivetevi
al mio canale e cliccate sulla
campanella vicino al tasso d'iscrizione
per rimanere sempre aggiornati su tutti
i nuovi video e come sempre ricordatevi
di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social
instagram facebook e tiktok
io vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo video ciao